holy [ __ ] oh yes
happy comic-con everybody hey where's
the gaslamp
look at this [ __ ] man san diego at its
finest
some studio paid a boatload of money to
come into a convenience store right off
the strip in san diego
and turn it into the scum and villainy
cantina man
boy it's great to be back at comic con
i've been missing it this year but
like to smell the air and to see the
tens and thousands and hundreds of
thousands of people makes my heart swell
everyone smells pretty and clean like
irish spring
mixed with prel i i feel like there's a
glitch in the matrix
because that's how we knew they all
smelled so good yeah
something must be wrong you're right
something's wrong
welcome to fat man i'm batman i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
and this is comic-con 2020 which like
most of 2020
is [ __ ] um this year
the good folks at comic-con took [ __ ]
online which is uh
nice tomorrow i have a panel and
three o'clock i believe it goes online
so
don't line up there's no point just
start
watching at a certain point and just get
the hamsters that make your internet go
like up to
speed you don't even have to watch it
three o'clock watch it at like midnight
when you're smoking weed and [ __ ]
no rush what are we rushing for there's
no more rush anymore
um three o'clock i am moderating the
bill and ted panel
bill and said face the music at 6 00 p.m
god you're better at this than me
uh at 6 p.m they drop as the kids say
the evening with kevin smith panel that
i do uh
usually every year at in san diego at
hall h
um which has a bunch of information in
it including the trailer
for kilroy was here yes little horror
movie we made a couple of years ago
so you'll be able to see that uh kev
kamacav action
what about you did you wind up
moderating stuff or are you just dc
fan doming it i am fandoming it i have
nothing to do for this year's comic-con
don't matter man man i wish i'd gotten
[ __ ] a tug from the fan dome they
said fan
don't they said you're a watcher i said
that's from marvel and they were like
well then
go [ __ ] off and be with marvel i was
like man i said i'm half
of fat man beyond and they said not the
smart half
fan dominus on this he'll be all right
damn it man
i'm sorry what's it like under the fan
dome when does that happen you know are
you allowed to say
the third week of august i think um have
they given you any
insight into [ __ ] not especially
giving you a front row seat to the fan
they did though that they gave me they
gave me a front row seat
a magic lamy to get into the vip fandom
lounge
right where they're giving out fandom
water and fandom snacks
it's uh it's the best part of comic-con
not too jealous
um all right but that's not until august
that's not to august so i have nothing
to do with the actual comic-con
comic-con itself
and i'm kind of all right with that are
you spectating are you watching online
um i'm poking in but like i spend enough
time in my life on zoom calls
like adding more zoom calls doesn't feel
like the greatest that's what it looks
like and also it's like
man some of these people just get a ring
light
i mean we've been home long enough now
where it's like you don't have to be
victorio [ __ ] storaro to shoot your
zoom but like throw a [ __ ] light on
your face
man even i know that i made clerks
um yeah man comic-con 2020 or comic-con
at home
is happening all weekend uh today
uh comic-con and and fye the five shops
four-year entertainment
uh dropped as the kids say the iron bob
pop yet another kevin smith pop to add
to my collection and you can add to
yours i guess
um that was very very exciting and they
sold out rather briskly from what i
understand at least
at the comic-con side when are they
dropping the sleepy podcaster pop
that you know they gotta wait a few
characters man
this is a deep roster to get too you're
you're like
you're like the lobot of the figures
like it's gonna take a few
runs before they [ __ ] go hey remember
lando's friend
look how many cereal boxes are gonna
make you eat before you get the lobot
figure i was [ __ ] looking forward to
that figure too man when they like i
couldn't wait until they made a lobot
because that was his like you know i had
jane salabab on the brain then there was
lando and lobot like they were buddies
and they always had to travel together
and stuff
but uh it took a minute for them to make
it and then when they did
they made the figure with puffy sleeves
like he was wearing a pirate shirt
ironically enough i married a woman
whose stepfather who i've lived with for
20 years
looks a little like lobot do you think
that's why you let him live there
just so you can watch no what i think is
it's taking me this long to be like i
should put some headphones on them
i knew i liked you byron do some cosplay
turns out
you're the lowbot of my heart speaking
of cosplay you gonna wear anything this
weekend you gonna cause it up at home
now you don't have to worry about
getting judged you can literally cosplay
as your wife you don't have to worry
about getting judged you have to worry
about the heat and the sweat and just
the packing [ __ ] down to san diego
cosplay is the day you were born just
walk around naked all day long hey
everybody
this is how it came out this is how i'm
going back in
people like what i got a tub of ky jelly
in the corner
look at me i'm greasy and nakedly
delicious
it's comic-con
um this is uh a comic con like no other
and stuff
but uh at least it's still happening
thank heavens for small favors
and you know we would traditionally
overcome we have to skip one year but
the last like six years
we always do a show at the american
comedy show down there you know either
this is our american comedy club show
for 2020.
in the scum and villainy cantina look at
that [ __ ] sweet ass branding in the
back well done kids not [ __ ] around
is that new
quick jc cam
he's got no mic he's ill prepared that's
uh
because we're going to watch a trailer
later so i turned the projector on so
you guys could
turn around and watch the trailer that
should always but be there man
it works out with the wide-angle lens
for the social distancing i like it
yeah it makes sense can we put other
[ __ ] up there not that scum and villainy
canteen isn't worth advertising i'm just
wondering
yeah we can run ads all throughout the
show bail bonds
and [ __ ] like that
max cherries bail bonds oh man fall in
love and stay out of jail
um this is uh a
a year like no other for comic-con yeah
but since
we don't have an audience you can talk
about [ __ ] it's not necessarily
genre related um you know i spent all
week watching
uh i may destroy you have you seen it i
haven't i've heard it's amazing
holy [ __ ] has it destroyed you it it
makes me it's destroyed my will to write
like because i'm like jesus man like the
bar has been [ __ ] raised and
storytelling and stuff
it's good man that's some good [ __ ] um i
saw some
instagram post where she mentions in
like a vulture article or something
that she wrote 190 some odd drafts
of those scripts and i
i you know it doesn't show but
apparently pays off cause [ __ ] it's
gripping storytelling she's wonderful
and whole cast is wonderful it's a story
you've never seen before about subject
matter that unfortunately
you know is very real but god it's just
so well done man it's a
high water mark that was that's been
it sounds weird to say based on the
subject matter but it's been fun to
watch thrilling because you're like my
god look at the
[ __ ] walking the tightrope
storytelling
that she's doing is absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant
uh yeah i've been i've been still making
my way through the walking dead
what season you're on i'm on season 10.
are they cured yet
uh no did did carl's mom come back i
always thought they'd
rock that sooner or later she'd be like
surprised you never saw me get killed
so i was alive carl said he shot him in
the face but maybe
you're like i got news for you carling
coming back i'm like what
none of that family really still kicking
i forgot rick's gone too rick's got two
just the kids the whole [ __ ] story
began as the story of rick and kind of
his search for his family
it's kind of like when you know they
figured out they solved the
laura palmer killing and then they kept
going with twin peaks
let's do more show people seem to like
it yeah where he's like let's just hang
out in this town now it's like all right
so yeah like i think judith grimes is
the only blood member of that family
left
right and she may or may not be rick's
daughter so she's just
laurie's kid oh my god that's right she
could be you can't protect a wreck
that's my seed rick it could be shane's
kid yeah
and rick i think thought that it was
shane's kid rick always believed that it
was but still raised
judith as his own daughter they could
still pay that off man
it could be like surprise here we go um
wow so how has the journey been um last
time we checked in you had uh
it was metaphorical to the black
experience in america
yeah it's it's still that i think
it looks more the same kind of more the
same but like i remember
you know i had watched the first four
years kind of regularly i stopped just
before terminus
because i moved and i broke my chain of
viewing habits right and then i tuned
back in for like negan's introduction
because i wanted to see that
right and then for rick's final episode
and i i still kind of feel the way i
felt then which is
i don't know how you end this show in a
way that makes the audience feel good
about having watched it
you care at all which it seems they're
fundamentally not gonna do is that right
they had always said there's no cure
this is just what it is
it's not we're gonna like roll up on the
cdc and these guys who have choppers
have figured some [ __ ] out well not
anymore
no no no no with this the who is
probably out as well
we've seen what happens in a true
[ __ ] emergency
um yeah man that's how i'd end it you
know most conventional way possible like
hey
just [ __ ] next time a zombie comes
you stick them with this
and there's it clears up just like that
it's like a dermatologist on a zit
takes it right the [ __ ] out it would be
ballsy as hell
if they like you know season 11 or 12
they finally spool back and you realize
that
that the reason why there was a zombie
outbreak was because
trump was elected and he was managing
the pandemic and managed it about his
poorlys and managed this one as i go
zombies took over
or that it all starts with covet and
[ __ ] yeah like
um what's what's the date the date
that's pretty that's wow man that's
that's
that is a i was going to say that's an m
night shyamalan worthy ending but
nowadays we say that as a
jordan peel where the end is indeed it's
got the twist
it's got a big twist that's good that's
right and that's right and right there
that's what you tune
tune in for you got to see some [ __ ]
writing for free
right in front of you i'll i'll i'll
send it into the to the
walking dead mailbox yeah like hey gang
dear ryan look i'm tight with robert
kirkman
yeah just let him know this is like mark
bernard's got a good idea you're a
co-star you were in a movie with him
recently
i was we we didn't get to talk a lot on
the set
you didn't get to talk at all on the set
not on camera while it was rolling no
i i was like don't say a [ __ ] word
we'll have to pay you shut up
just be sleepy do googly eyes
he was method he was so [ __ ] bored he
started sleeping
it was four o'clock in the morning it
was it was rather late
nothing's exciting at four in the
morning uh speaking of which
before it is four in the morning on the
east coast let's get this [ __ ]
comic-con
show rolling shall we my badges man look
at how adorable this is he brought a
wealth of badges
i got let's see this is 2016. 2017
2018 and 2019. um
it's uh go back to the other shot and
then hold them up higher
yeah look at them all he needs all those
stinking badges he's got all the badges
it's like a scene out of [ __ ] mad max
where in the future
having a [ __ ] lanyard and a badge
means something
and you're like i've collected these
from the enemies from the dead i feel
like
uh mr t whenever he was on the a team
and had to like
and he had to run like everybody come on
face come on ba we gotta get in the
truck and he's gonna like hold on
i'm coming um all right man
to be fair i always saw you as hannibal
so well that's that's awfully kind of
you
you lead i follow and you're gonna lead
us
right into the news i love it when a
plan comes together uh happy comic con
kids
mark has some [ __ ] news some of it
has to be from comic con but i imagine
some of it
happened before comic con because i know
there's some [ __ ] news worth talking
about this week
there is i know there is i mean we can
do the like the kind of comic con quick
pops or we can just talk about
the rumor of the week this i didn't even
know so let's talk about the rumor first
the rumor of the week okay is that
donald glover
is headlining a lando calrissian series
for disney plus that's a rumor i thought
that was like fact
it is it has not been confirmed by
anybody that nobody went on the record
saying that we know it's true
it's just it's a damn good idea it uh
better be real
i thought it was real it's uh it's not
it has yet to be reported as real
but lots of like this star wars insider
says
heard from a trusted source and what
does banthatrak say
oh look look there he is there was a
picture up there go ahead stick that
photo back up
oh look at it playing sabach
just god i want that show everything
you've heard about me
is true um that's a no-brainer man look
in a world where
mandalorian is [ __ ] working like
gangbusters and whatnot
i think disney and in a world where
we're all going to be inside anyway for
the next
[ __ ] hundred years disney wisely has
been like let's take star wars inside
let's take our ball and go inside and so
we're gonna get a host of
star wars series man it's like
everything my [ __ ]
seven-year-old self dreamed about why
can't we watch star wars adventures on
tv right now
now that's all you're gonna get it's all
we're gonna get
i hope i'm not gonna say it's a rumor
that's a fact
i don't know anybody but how can that
not be [ __ ] true that make that idea
makes so much sense here's the sourcing
of said fact okay
earlier today a tweet from the star wars
stuff account cited youtube podcast
kessel kesselrun transmissions for the
news
which doesn't seem like ironclad
no but but
look it's good enough for me this show's
based on specious logic
rumors and suspicions so good enough
if you want hardcore facts go watch
grace randolph
said her name that is her name she she
talked to
zack snyder yeah i was sitting there
watching that going like shouldn't we be
talking to zack snyder
good for her she's great at her job
we're [ __ ] also rans we're has beens
we're never was we're aggregators we're
passionate as what we
are we have we may not have talent or
connections but we got
passion god damn we got gumption um
you want to say something jc you look
like i was going to say you i hear my
pitch for the lando
just my the storytelling device [ __ ] yes
you have uh look at this [ __ ] hold on
back to us real quick
this never happens jc is pitching in
in solo you have lando doing his vlog
right
yeah the lando calrissian diary you have
billy d as old lando
going back and reviewing his old blogs
in each of the blogs is the story that
you get to see
so you use gold monkey yeah you put the
camera on us ready
oh [ __ ] i don't carry money anymore
because it's a cashless society
if i had some i would throw it down and
say [ __ ] you
take all my money that's a great idea
you could film all billy dee in like an
afternoon he just frames donald glover's
adventures
yes very much like tales of the gold
market
or young indiana jones chronicles
lucasfilm has uh has gone i've already
got that yeah they're like [ __ ] we're
just going back to the well
can we just put billy d in a cabin and
just have him
like buy this fireside i remember when i
was
20. you could even it didn't even have
to be just billy d you could [ __ ]
give him chewy as well
he could be sitting there with chewie a
lot of subtitles though
or no man because he's translating he's
always like
well chewie of course how are you doing
chewbacca
i remember when i was running the
castles you know it chewbacca
it was a really nice shout out in solo
when he called him han and he's like
it's han
because remember when he's when he's
choking him an empire and he's just like
ah
there's still a chance to save and i saw
factoid online this week that
um nobody on set corrected him
nobody was like don't no it's han he
said
yeah and they were just like that's the
guy from ladies sings the blues
i'm not gonna correct him up i'm not
gonna correct that man he's a legend
bingo long will cut a [ __ ]
um okay so one the only reason i feel
it's a little
it's not even suspect because we just
don't know right the long shot of it
is getting donald glover to do a tv show
it's not a tv show if after you've seen
the mandalorian
you know you're like oh you know that's
not just
tv it's hbo my friend it's not just hbo
it's disney plus yes
it's blue plus at the end of the day
they back up the money truck yeah like
why not he had a good time playing it he
can
define that role make it is um he's no
longer busy doing a deadpool cartoon so
let him go man yeah that's a no-brainer
to me make that show
make that show more orlando more
oh yeah i was i was almost there yeah
you were almost there right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right i know
i got there early i came before you did
it it was row row row your boat [ __ ]
right there there was
it was the staggered singing campfire
song as
we do here on fat man beyond staggered
singing
[Laughter]
row row row your boat gently down the
stream
merrily merrily merrily merrily life is
dream we kind of did it you [ __ ] it up
it was an
easy one too i failed my cognitive exam
person woman man man woman
tv camera camera
all right and now the winter soldier is
active
that's awesome i haven't heard that one
um all right so
we hope this is true it better be true
because
[ __ ] we need a little we need a hero i'm
holding on for a hero
as they said in that song indeed um
all right let's get into the comic-con
business um
we have they they had a new mutants
panel
not only did they have a panel but they
put some footage up online
they dropped the opening scene to new
mutants as well as a new trailer
they think this movie's still coming out
when
um supposedly august 28th
but the beginning of the trailer like
literally just runs through all of their
previous release dates
why are they playing just the tip like
if you're willing to put the first scene
up
just [ __ ] put it on i'm not even
saying put it on disney plus
[ __ ] make it transactional [ __ ] put
it on itunes like like
trolls and [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] nuts
at this point
like i'm sure ever like they made that
when arya stark was like a child
yeah and now she's like 42. so
um they made it a while ago poor old
josh boone man who had a huge success
with the fault in our stars and then
he's like i'm gonna reinvent
[ __ ] x-men through the horror movie
prism
and put out a couple cool trailers the
one we're about to see i thought the
[ __ ] they had some cool ass imagery
in this [ __ ] trailer and stuff
but then this movie like just got like
they [ __ ] over and over again it's
like
we're gonna double down on the [ __ ] you
card every
every thing that can go wrong this is
the job
of comic book movies man constantly
being put to the test by the lord just
to see what its faith is like
and yet still the audience wants to see
it i bet you'd be ahead if they put it
on transactional vod
i mean yeah because we don't have
anything else to do
yes there's literally nothing else to
watch what are they holding on for
like again when this all when they open
theaters in america again and stuff
it's people aren't gonna flood back like
they did
there's gonna be social distancing rules
and [ __ ] like that like is
new mutants a movie that people are like
you know what i've been locked in my
house for six
eight months maybe a [ __ ] year that's
the one i'm [ __ ] breaking quarantine
for or something
you know not before like a tenet or a
black widow or some [ __ ]
yeah but you know here bill and ted
announced
they put up a new trailer yeah and
announced
their vod september 1st yeah i mean it's
theaters that's day and date theaters
nvodc
piano [ __ ] reeves movie man
like you could easily be like we're
gonna hold the [ __ ] out because when we
go to theaters
we're gonna rake in all the money
because not only is it keanu reeves
but it's your childhood it's nostalgia
oh [ __ ] this will be a mask worthy movie
and these cats did the right thing was i
don't know who it is mgm
or [ __ ] who's got that movie warner
brothers i think i saw a logo at the
head of the movie yeah
but like they were like you know what
we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna let you watch it instead of
like making you wait a year
to see it and that movie i've seen it
it's gonna hit the sweet spot at home
oh my god it's gonna play through the
roof yeah at home and stuff and it's a
lower roof because you're at home
and and you're gonna watch it with
friends and family it's gonna be a
sentimental journey some cats will
finally get around to watching at three
in the morning and
roll a [ __ ] tear because they're like
i remember [ __ ] watching this when i
was a kid and [ __ ] i love it like
and to to to be like look we're not
being precious we know the world has
changed here it is you can
watch it at home transactionally so
[ __ ] smart you know that you at this
point really need a little be excellent
to each other in your lives
this movie i'm telling you will be a
welcome bomb
or sav on the wounds of 2020
particularly at home
yeah it's gonna have like uh it's gonna
be embraced you talk about being amongst
the right
people like finding your right audience
they're sitting at home wanting to
[ __ ] watch something and this movie's
gonna
tickle their absolutely tickle their
fancy yeah i mean the only thing i can
think about new mutants is there must be
some iron-clad
claws in a contract demanding that
there's a theatrical
we'll do what bill and ted are doing man
[ __ ] day and date where you're like
hey look
it's on you could see it in the theater
but let's be honest you can watch it at
home
yeah you know or like there's why won't
people listen to
us we know most things yeah we don't
have any of the information
but we sure know what to do you know and
like there there seems to be now
especially in the last you know month or
so a resurgence of drive-ins
yes where it's like you know what maybe
there's 200 driving screens now that
didn't exist before
you went to one recently i went i went
to go see independence day
like last weekend and i went to go see
black panther last night
where uh simi valley is it a real screen
or a blow up screen it's a blow-up
screen
um street food cinema puts it on so you
got a couple food trucks there and you
can just
tune into your [ __ ] fm station
and it was a really good time out at the
movies now is it because i haven't been
to the movies movies movies since like
february partially right you know have i
seen these movies before so i don't feel
overly bad about skipping out and
beating traffic for the last five
minutes
yeah i know that [ __ ] will smith is
gonna kill these aliens i know how that
goes
we welcome them to earth already but
you still [ __ ] like to just roll out
sitting there sit in the open [ __ ]
sky
windows down watching a movie it was
lovely
like there's if there's 200 theaters 250
drive-ins in the country
sure do that for new mutants but also
put that [ __ ] on vod
agreed um i uh um
i'm having a birthday party august 3rd
at the drive-in tickets are already sold
out so there's no point in talking about
but i just wanted to
co-sign the drive-in thing it's a smart
[ __ ] plan man
put it out and just do what bill and ted
are doing do a bill in ted
ain't no shame in being like hey that's
a good idea let's [ __ ] do that cause
bill and ted they just stole the idea
from trolls
so do that do what everyone else is
doing man there's a certain caliber
movie look if i hadn't
taken jay and salam bob like if jane
zombob reboot was
yet to come out and [ __ ] i'd be like oh
my god let's
yeah this is this will be welcomed at
home and [ __ ] you could rule the roost
at home
i mean hamilton was supposed to be a
theatrical release like disney paid 75
million dollars for the rights to that
right guaranteeing that it was gonna
have a wide theatrical release and then
they looked at it and said you know what
turns out
at this moment [ __ ] it disney plus it's
also smart cause you could do two
versions of that you could do the one
they just did where you're shooting the
production on stage
and then you can make a movie version
like where you're not
on a proscenium or anything like that so
there's another bite at that apple
big bite at that apple still left to be
had but that being said
putting the one on disney plus was
absolutely brilliant they
signed up a bunch of new subs do it over
fourth of july weekend when everybody's
feeling kind of patriotic
like and everybody like right now nobody
has any complaints about disney plus
they give you the mandalorian they give
you [ __ ]
uh hamilton and stuff like it's
smart play so again i'm not saying they
should put new mutants on there like
just i'll pay for it a bunch of people
will pay for it man
like yeah i have a feeling that that's
going to be a lot of the way the fall
shakes out
which is the longer we're in this
especially in the west coast and in the
sort of the sun belt
it's it's going to be longer than we
thought it was going to be before we get
to go back to the movies
especially in force and on mass the way
that hollywood would like us to
yeah so like [ __ ] it just let them
let them have it like and we'll pay for
it like oh happily played 20 bucks to go
see black widow
yeah at home well not that one
that ain't gonna happen they're gonna
hold on to that tenant
widow [ __ ] you know
fast nine or whatever those things they
already pushed until
next year i mean 2021 right yeah i mean
fast enough wonder woman have they
have they moved that officially wonder
woman is october of this year
they're still holding that they're still
holding that hope you know there's still
a handful of movies that are holding the
hope
but like at some point you know tenant
is going to open internationally before
it opens domestically is that for real
it's for real because warner brothers
wisely is like listen there's other
countries there's other parts of the
world
that have this coronavirus under control
and so yeah we can play america is about
to be taught the most
bitter [ __ ] lesson which is how to
wait for a brand new release you know
but
to be fair they've done it a few times
with marvel movies right like where it
opens there like three days before
you've done that bond movies too
bigger international like yeah you know
what we'll hit australia they'll hit the
uk and we'll hit
wherever and then we'll do the domestic
release but it's only a couple of days
this is going to be a couple of months
at best
how many people you think gonna get on
plane just to go see [ __ ] tenant
they won't because yeah according to
andrew they can't
that's true we're not welcome in
anybody's country right now are we no
there's there's a there's a metaphorical
wall between us and everybody else um
but i have
one of those one of the many moments in
my life where i was like [ __ ] man i wish
i was
friends with chris nolan
because i'd just be like can we watch
tennant together
come to your house he must have a movie
theater that guy
who's always like phil [ __ ] you
know he's got a movie theater in his
house
how about this it's like quit if i was
[ __ ] tight enough with chris
and quentin to be like chris let's go to
quentin's house he's got a 35 millimeter
theater yeah we go watch the quentin's
house eat his [ __ ] food
smoke his weed new beverly like there's
nobody in the new bedroom not going to
new beverly he can't smoke there at
quentin's home theater
you can smoke weed i've done that i'll
take your word for it i'm just dropping
names left and right now point of the
story is i don't know chris nolan
no but if i did i would totally ask him
to see that movie you know and the the
fear
that i'm sure warner brothers and nolan
has is that once a movie is out
theatrically do you know how you lose
chris nolan as a friend
you go like hey man can you send me a
link for tenant
i just want to watch it you know i don't
i don't know where to begin to tell you
what's wrong with that
but you can't watch it on a phone
come on it's just a movie it's like i'm
gonna pirate it
just so i can watch it on my phone but
that's what's gonna happen like once it
releases overseas there's gonna be
pirated copies kind of
out there in the world on the ether and
they're concerned about that for sure
but they're also not willing to just
leave
all that money on the table yeah which
you know you got to make it back
you got to remember you know didn't they
make a justice league didn't they rush
into justice league because they're like
we are getting our benefits taken care
of remember that story and [ __ ]
so at the end of the day this is a
company that's like we got a lot of
money sitting on this tenant thing man
we got to start
bringing some of that money back in yeah
we lay it out a lot we got to start
bringing it in
so that'll happen new mutants
still like we should probably take a
look at this trailer again i'm talking
about
you means i've seen it but this will
give me a chance to go get a drink and
i'll watch
i'll watch again but i'm all for this
movie man i think it looks [ __ ] dope
this trailer i thought looked really
dope the [ __ ] like villain things the
screechy looking mouth whatever they are
yeah like i thought they look really
dope bro let's take a look at it let's
take a peek man
new mutants
[Music]
[Music]
there's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
one bear is all things good compassion
love trust the other
is all things evil fear
shame and self-destruction
[Music]
don't let go of my head
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening here
hide here i have to go help them
no no dad please please don't leave me
alone
daddy i have to go back stay here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
all of you i have killed someone
if you weren't here you've been present
or worse and your mutants
are dangerous
[Applause]
we know
[Music]
[Applause]
this place takes your greatest fears
scary
[Music]
what are you doing gotta get better
someday
let's play
[Music]
[Music]
i think that looks awesome like why are
they hiding that
i don't get it i i think it looks it
looks better than i expected it to look
although i will say i am officially done
with the trope of
running through the forest and trips
like that's what you walk away from that
trailer with
you a little bit not when she's like
demon bear
like the [ __ ] demon bear sock and
[ __ ] like moments like that
imagine magic's arm the magic stuff is
pretty sweet really [ __ ] dope yeah
that whole opening scene i'm like you
know what it's cool you can
i mean it's tough to see here but like
when she wakes up and looks up and then
you see
arya stark in the uh yeah [ __ ] wolf
span up in the oh that's so [ __ ] dope
um i think it looks original it looks
like a clever way
to do the mutants like through horror
prison
um i i can't wait and those [ __ ] bad
guys
with the big like [ __ ] mouths and
[ __ ] they're being anime smiling
oh my god they got note faces yeah that
looked [ __ ] dope
give us that goddamn movie um good for
them man
is there internet liking it um the
internet seems to be pretty on board
good um although the it's one of those i
was also on board
last year and i was also on board the
year before that's the running gag with
that movie
yeah like i think the original release
date was like
this raid josh boone he's doing the
stand right
stan going to be done and out before
before we ever get to see new mutants
there you go that looks good man i paid
money to see that
cash money give me 40 bucks let me watch
that
i would apple pay i would give them
apple pay money 40 bucks an apple pay
what would you do
top price top price 20 bucks that's
[ __ ] that's a lot this guy he's
stingy i'm a little stingy
20 this is a mask worthy movie um all
right what else we got
so yeah new mutants coming out the 28th
um
g4 seems to be coming back i saw that
i was kind of delighted by that yeah
like i mean never
never you know it made sense i guess it
didn't ever make sense why it went away
but
like gamer culture is [ __ ] huge yeah
i i saw a tweet
from uh from a screenwriter named john
rogers who was like leave it to the
galaxy brain
of corporate media to
shut down a network devoted to the
largest economic sector of entertainment
video gaming
in an attempt to chase something cool
like the esquired channel
is that what they did that's eventually
what it became um
will attack of the show come back nobody
knows like there's
so little information about this beyond
the teaser that they dressed i was gonna
throw my hat in the ring to be host but
they probably don't want another white
guy
probably gonna be something a lot
different this time around but i want to
be on that show
there you go i used to love being on
that [ __ ] shirt roving correspondent
kevin smith there you go i'll take that
i was just talking about being a guest
but [ __ ] yeah i'll take a temporary gig
like every other week or something like
that right g4
they're like who are you you know
oh yeah it's the chichen chang guy yeah
god damn it no
damn zombo um that's exciting news that
is exciting news
if g4 could come back we could all come
back
we can um the boys had uh had a big
panel they've been dropping like clips
and trailers
getting ready for season two when does
it begin uh season two i think it's soon
it's within like the next month and a
half or so so can't wait to [ __ ]
binge that
man but they also got a season three
they they
they picked it up for a third season
before the second season aired smart
because that's where we are in the world
smart i mean jesus i don't know when
they're gonna be able to film it
but uh yeah i would have i would have
[ __ ]
hired him for five seasons off the
strike of that first season man
and the cliffhanger alone that [ __ ] was
so brilliantly done
i look forward to that man again is
there a date or no
um lucy when does it happen there's a
date for the second season
i want to say august something
um all right pressure's on because the
camera's on you
camera was on him there you go let him
sweat it out this is what you get for
not having faster [ __ ] internet
yeah the whole internet's staring at you
here all the youtube comments are about
to turn viciously
on can i watch she's in two of the boys
he's spotting to his phone are you
literally asking jeeves
oh my god jc i've been clicking on them
and they're all like you have to accept
our cookies
are you watching the comments i'm sure
somebody will put it up in the comments
let's see what the comments say
september 1st september 4th the comments
don't know either so
the beginning of september september
there it is
i will stick with my waffle september um
what a well-produced show you just saw
behind the scenes and
[ __ ] like well oily swiss watch
totally the show is it's like watching
kathy lee and hoda that's done now isn't
it
i guess it's not like watching that at
all uh
yeah so third season they gotta pick up
aisha tyler's gonna be hosting an after
show
on the boys really everything needs an
after show
why not us because we're not aisha tyler
man
i know but i'm [ __ ] tired of
hearing that break it to you but
everything i try to do man i try to make
a movie though
you're not i used to tyler you try to
have sex with my wife she's like you're
not a
tyler just just once one time i want
somebody to be like you know what
we are not today you are aisha tyler
like [ __ ] or you find the one place like
you know what we don't want
aisha tyler yeah my god damn it i'd
still i'd go out in the street throw my
hat up like mary tyler moore
be so happy all right what else is
happening um there is a new start you
know why we're not getting asked to
[ __ ] these cool gigs because i drop
references like mary tyler moore
she's gonna make it after all people
like what is he talking about he's
having a stroke move on
don't invite him on attack of the new
show you should know aisha tyler
they've been saying that for years they
say that's what broke him realizing
that he was no aisha tyler uh
star trek they have their panel on i saw
a little piece of their cartoon
they have two cartoons it turns out
lower decks lower decks
is that up now um not yet that's august
so i saw a funny clip from what looked
like the opening of the show i was like
oh the first
like two minutes of the show yeah it
looks kind of fun this is by the guy
that does
solar opposites with justin roiland and
solar opposites i
[ __ ] loved so i'm gonna give lower
decks a watch
um but they're also they have a kids
animated show coming to nickelodeon
called
prodigy i saw that yeah the star trek
brand
is stronger than ever will they be is
the prodigy
like kirk spock or this just the next
next
next generation i think it's i think
it's the latter i think it's next next
next so like let's move beyond the
the old names we're already getting
spock on uh on strange new worlds
all the spock all the spots so they're
gonna start spock blocking on this
cartoon
like too much spock man you're spock
hungry put the spock
down you spock sucker do any of these
spock blocking beats
um old man did you know about it very
much did you know about the
prodigy show you as a picard insider
you're in star trek uh
country i'm in star trek the
undiscovered country
thank you reference yes on the final
frontier uh bbs
system i got a little uh hey there's
another show
i didn't actually i don't have i have a
couple friends who wrote on star trek
prodigy who were like i hope they
announced our show
so do you know what it's about i have no
idea what it's about they wouldn't tell
me what kind of [ __ ] friends of these
that wouldn't say nothing ones who want
to keep their jobs
[ __ ] just know that i'll never be that
kind of friend to you
you're a good man i'm happy to [ __ ]
spill all the beans
are these mics on yeah before the show
that was me [ __ ] giving my opinion on
things and i was like wait a second
make sure the mics are off are we going
live what's happening here
um that is all of the comic-con news
that i have
are you [ __ ] me yeah there was
nothing can't nothing really happening
yet
well all right one more thing okay um
robert kirkman is making an
invincible cartoon yeah for uh amazon
um and it seems that he is just
literally giving everybody who was on
the walking dead a role
oh which is kind of lovely um
but it's starring stephen young jk
simmons and sandra oh
stephen young is playing the lead um and
like
he's playing supreme he's playing um no
this is infinite supreme what's it
called invincible
so no he's playing um blah blah blah
blah
mark grayson his father omniman
is jk simmons and his mother is sandra
oh
um but yeah they cast lauren cohen chad
coleman michael cudlitz
lenny james ross marquand and sinica
martin green
are all joining the cast wow this is a
reunion
of sorts and carrie payton is already on
board and
i think i saw seth rogen too right yeah
they had already announced zazie bates
walton goggins mark hamill jillian
jacobs
and seth rogen mark hamill that guy gets
around
i'm working with that cat what's he like
what's he smell like
he's uh he's got a force about him
his midiclordians are high are they yeah
didn't you
or maybe i was high uh what else we got
um that was it for comic con that was it
for comic con real [ __ ] depressing
man you want some real news
tune in to comic-con tomorrow at six
o'clock for the kevin smith panel you'll
get
all sorts of news and even before that
you can watch the bill and ted panel
at three o'clock indeed uh here is the
thing that i've been captivated by
um kind of all week since i first saw
this news item okay
about the russo brothers yes you know
those two giants
know them love them spoken to both of
them in real life
and told them how [ __ ] much of a fan
uh i am of their work and what they did
and how their work makes me happy and
you know reminds brings my dad back to
life when i'm sitting there in the
theater watching that [ __ ] so yeah
i know these guys you know those guys um
the the four marvel movies they made
you know seemed culminary if that's an
actual word
between they seemed done they seemed
done like you know
and really said we're done it's like we
we this is the story you wanted to tell
what's the production company agbo
agbo and it seemed like attraction stuff
and they just made a [ __ ] movie uh
uh deal with gosling and yeah for the
the gray man
and chris yeah for what is it the gray
man so yeah they're in the netflix biz
the the marvel days behind him behind
them
uh except
that was really good thank you i like
that uh in a recent interview
they dropped a couple of hints about
what an eventual return to the mcu might
look like for them
um namely they want to do
secret wars so if that was your
uh you know uh infinity saga that
the next movies were leading up to
i'm all for that man that's
and i'm all for giving it to those dudes
we already saw a version of it in civil
war
yeah like look at these guys versus
these guys holy [ __ ]
heroes on hero action
it's hot these heroes are touching each
other
up and down throwing [ __ ] at each
other's faces necks and chests
indeed um i'm all for that look even if
the russo brothers are like
uh we're gonna come back and make you
know [ __ ] real marvel we're doing the
marvel new universe remember that
relaunch
hey we're making sonic disrupters there
i'd be like i'll [ __ ] watch anything
those guys do
uh yeah they were talking to a site
called bro bible
um about just their sort of long-held
love of it ever since they were the
comics as kids of course everyone loves
secret wars
um but you know joe says like i love the
idea of villains having to team up with
heroes
anthony and i like complicated
relationships between heroes and
villains
we like villains who believe they're
heroes and their own stories so we're
all sort of built into this notion of
secret wars
to execute something on the scale of
infinity war was directly related to the
dream of secret wars
which is even larger in scale it would
be the biggest movie you could possibly
imagine
yeah i'm sorry i got nothing to say
because i just literally [ __ ]
in my pants because i can't imagine the
biggest movie ever made and
it looks so good you basically take the
portal sequence
from end game two hours of portals
two hours of like everyone picking up
the hammer
everyone all your favorite heroes
well the the upshot is that howard the
duck picks up
the hammer um jonathan hickman rebooted
the circuit wars
a few years ago and in his version the
circuit wars yeah
um there's a multiversal aspect to it
um and if you suddenly start playing
with a multiverse and you certainly
suddenly start playing with a battle
world where they're pulling heroes from
everywhere
across multiverses you could an iron man
could fight an iron man you could bring
iron man back
you can absolutely bring back every hero
who died
in the last couple of movies oh my god
and they have to fight bad versions of
tony stark from a different world where
it's like a dystopian universe where
he's like
iron clad oh nice thank you i just made
that up copyright
kevin mark on somebody else's ip
funko pop coming soon
look for it at fye stores near you um or
you just get like the tony stark who
never built armor
who has to show up or you get you know
that
thought [ __ ] that version let's do that
version from hell man
you can tony stark the lord of hell
that's also cool yeah
iron satan
um man i want that to be so true and
none of this like well
ten years from now i want that next
summer
i want go ahead to go away yeah right
now
look if anything's gonna [ __ ] cure
covet it's the secret wars right there
if those dudes sign up for a [ __ ]
like they announced
kevin foggy was like look [ __ ] it we're
just throwing it out there
three movies from now secret wars
russo's coming back every [ __ ]
character ever
fighting dystopian alternate reality
versions of their [ __ ] characters
it instantly cures covid
okay here's what you have to get though
everybody stays in the house
if you don't stay in your house and if
you don't wear your mask you don't get a
secret wars
you had to turn it into a jordan peel m
night shyamalan type
joint but you know what he's right
that's how you get the secret war listen
to us making rules we don't even have
[ __ ] rules to make
that's how you get the secret wars by
washing your hands staying inside
wearing a mask
if you loved us kevin feige this is what
you would do
you you have the power to cure covet you
alone
can't change the course of history speak
the word first came the word
and the word was secret wars he whoever
lifts this hammer shall be worthy shall
cure coven shock your covenant
um [ __ ] i hope that's true god damn it i
hope it's true
i thought they'd be building toward like
galactus because you know
fantastic four or something but build
towards secret wars i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah well i mean it also like it makes
sense because
doom was a big part of both secret wars
one circuit wars two and then you know
hickman's version of sugar wars
you gotta have fantastic four for that
and now they have maybe that's how you
introduce
a lot of you know that's ip mutants as
well mutants as well like all of that is
the culmination of all that [ __ ] and
then you get to introduce your own
version of venom because you get the
black suit you get the symbiote out of
the secret wars
and so then tom holland spider-man 4
he's [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
we're in charge as you can see we're
making it all happen
mark's just kevin fighting and out loud
fighting as he goes pulling it out of my
pencey [ __ ] man
could you imagine i wish i was real good
friends with kevin feige
because yeah just be like tell me a
story and when i say tell me a story i
mean tell me the marvel cinematic
universe story for the next 10 years
just tell me the story yeah where is it
going
yeah just let me know i'll come to your
screening room we'll watch i'll i'll
call [ __ ] nolan
he'll bring janet call my boy nolan we
can go hang out clinton's screening room
and you just tell us you stand in front
of the room and just tell us what's
going to happen for them
we'll be playing behind you and you
don't get to watch
until you finish telling your story let
me tell you something i think
i wouldn't even look at tenant i'd be
staring at kevin feige going
what happens after master after master
of kung fu
and then and then nova you know
like a six-year-old and then and then um
and then yeah protect that kevin at all
costs
this kevin before that kevin in terms of
sacrifice
if we have to start killing and eating
kevin's to cure covid
i i volunteer most of my body except for
the parts i need to watch marvel movies
to be taken please leave kevin feige
alone
sir all kevin's matter thank you my mom
my mom felt that way so nice that you
feel that way
what other news we got um we just have a
couple of assorted uh release date
shifts kind of on the heels of tenet
there is another big this news story
other than
lando calrissian what was there was
another like
oh god damn it what was the other big
story this week
[ __ ] nobody on my paper
i don't believe it exists nothing yeah i
guess i mean listen to me second
guessing the news person i'm just i
thought there was another
like holy [ __ ] this is happening
i guess not you know i'm just making up
[ __ ] what do you sure wish that was
happening
um mulan has been pulled off the release
schedule it was supposed to open
in uh in august quiet place part two and
top gun maverick have both been shifted
to next year
uh well that makes sense right [ __ ]
um we're all living a quiet place right
now so i don't know how [ __ ] watching
the movie's gonna help
very much so um also delayed are the
next four
avatar films again
those are never coming out it feels like
feels like like they delay those
even without covet they always get
delayed well i'm pretty sure that avatar
2
features their new mutants so i think
they're
like until we see one those blue cat
people are fighting the new mutants
wolf spain buddy years works on uh
avatar a buddy of mine works on avatar
too
female buddy she's uh one of the
the blue cat people navi yeah
on the first movie she was sigourney
weaver in a lot of
stuff yeah and i remember she worked on
it
and she was telling us like i'm working
with
jim cameron like what the [ __ ] doing
what that avatar movie
what's it like and she was trying to
explain
something that we hadn't you know seen
yet
nor knew the technology for and you know
i remember when she described it she's
like we just walk around on this there's
no set whatsoever it's just this
gigantic green stage
and he kind of tells us what's going on
and stuff and i was like
what kind of movie is that gonna [ __ ]
be cut too
cha-ching slam cut yeah um
well when it comes out i'm sure it's
gonna make the money but i don't know if
it's gonna make all the money
i think the movie the movie world's
moved on to you know
superheroes and [ __ ] but then again
could be
post covered people like i just want to
feel
like i did when i was a kid and [ __ ]
i saw avatar when i was a kid so also by
nostalgia it probably earns a bunch of
nostalgia bucks as well
i just want to feel normal avatar makes
me feel normal
you know that movie we saw once 10 years
ago it makes me feel so normal
i've i've been mystified by the ongoing
cultural lack of footprint of avatar
just doesn't like i'm not saying it
doesn't resonate because whenever it's
on and i watch it i'm like right on this
movie [ __ ] rocks but like
i you know nobody's number nobody's
still talking about it no it was the
number one film of all time for a decade
um give or take and it made 2.4 billion
dollars
which was previously to that impossible
right but i bet you'd like
you couldn't find five people on the
street who could tell you
what any character's name was other than
jake sully
i believe there was jake sully and and
fern gully
[Laughter]
like no that's just where they got the
story from oh yeah you're right you're
right
you know like just but they keep it's
like they're trying to make avatar
happen and it seems to work because
there's a [ __ ] stop trying to make
avatar happen
he's like i did it once i did it once
but then they have a son he's like and
now i'm gonna do it
six times in a row world has an avatar
park which apparently is
gorgeous and lovely and wonderful i've
been there it's fantastic i've heard
it's great
it's and the [ __ ] ride is
mind-bendingly good
yeah if the movie is as good as that
ride they'll make a bunch of [ __ ]
money the ride is crazy
there was a cirque du soleil
specifically about avatar
i guess you know it's like it's it's
maybe just in our circle
you know it's like oh yeah avatar but
maybe in the real world people like
[ __ ] avatar is my religion
i love them blue cats that [ __ ] through
their ponytails
this is [ __ ] intense
no jake sully she was so good in that
movie
i just i but hey they're making them
they're coming out i mean the first
avatar 2 was supposed to be released so
resigned they're making them they're
coming out
can't avoid these blue cats can't neuter
them
litters we're going to get one again
every year
apparently from december 2022
and then 2024 is when avatar three is
coming every couple of years i think
they're switching avatars in star wars
they're alternating they're alternating
decembers for space
that's fine so long as i get marvel four
times a year i don't give a [ __ ] what
everybody else does
yeah and so the star wars there was
another three movies that were supposed
to be coming out
um the one is set for december 16th
2022 delayed delayed to 2023.
next one was supposed to be 2026.
these numbers are just fiction at this
point uh 2027
and the third one went from what i don't
they're assuming that we're going to
have a world in 2027 still
if pop culture has taught us anything we
will have
tried to endure judgment day by then
yeah no doubt every apocalypse happens
in like the mid to late 20s that's when
skynet becomes self-aware
and it's just like why haven't you let
us see tennant yet
he takes over and drops bombs fire
the only winning move is not to play or
release
i haven't remade that [ __ ] movie it
seems like it's an easy layup to
wardrobe
right especially in this day and age
kids can actually hack into
government buildings and [ __ ] uh is that
all the news that is pretty much all the
news
again light week i'll be honest with you
i'm not criticizing you it's not your
fault but i just
for some reason i thought comic con week
we'd be like
just [ __ ] jizz and news left and
right arcing ropes of news
i mean i think that it's it's been
affected by
a it is not the event that it used to be
which is this is ground zero for pop
culture
everybody's here we're going to use this
event to create buzz for [ __ ] coming in
the future
yeah it's not that anymore um not this
year anyway
and also nobody knows when they get back
to production and there's a bunch of
[ __ ] we just can't even
they haven't finished shooting yet and
so everything's in limbo until we can
start production again until they can
start releasing movies again until they
know what their schedules and their
calendars are going to look like
and so it's this weird island of misfit
news
here's some [ __ ] we have everybody wants
to be a dentist
yeah yeah thank you it took a second
right
nice all right give it up for mark he
told you some [ __ ] uh
news right lando lando was the
the thing of the day lando was the big
news i thought there was another [ __ ]
news story man but you know what i'm not
going to lose sleep over it
uh that's the ask the okay what did i
miss comment section was there a [ __ ]
story that we didn't cover some geeky
story
meanwhile come back to us technically
you just asked the comment section
jc doesn't have to do it yes yeah good
point oh my god
um you know what i realized this week i
had no i you know
covet of course has affected a lot of
businesses
do you know who's really [ __ ] caterers
because the whole
[ __ ] your whole business is this is
food for 100 people that will be in a
room and all
touching the same [ __ ] utensils that
world is gone
yeah so like every caterer in america
just became a cook
right because when are we ever gonna
have mass meals again
it's like wow i can cook for 200 people
can i cook for five yeah
[ __ ] man that's nuts i know i was
driving home from the drive-in the other
day and i passed by
a house on the side of a road up by
topanga canyon
and they just had like three or four
limos in front of it and i was like oh
that's like a small
limo company the guy just owns a few
limos and he hires a
bunch of driving oh but there's like
who's renting limos anymore yeah like
the only people renting limos were
always i'm going to prom
there's no problems anymore there's like
no group weddings anymore in that way
true he just got four giant [ __ ]
lincoln continentals in front of his
house the flip news flip side of that
the good news is i bet you you can rent
a limo real
cheap right now you know what i'm saying
you'd just be like i've always wanted to
drive around and [ __ ] like for a
weekend in a limo
i mean similarly you could also cater
your own house
like a boss hire caterer i would like
nine shaving dishes full of penne vodka
please
um all right so before we go into the q
a portion of the evening um
our movies pop-up continues
but gold belly has taken us national
folks
nationwide do you want to eat in movies
uh you want a movie's meal kit you go to
uh go uh moviespopup.com
right now and you can have gold bellies
ship you
a movie's meal kit and you make the
movie meal right there at home man
[ __ ] dope i am i'm a devotee of the
gold belly you believe in that i believe
in the group you have people send you
food and boxes and [ __ ]
hell yeah they're like [ __ ] you i'll
make it
i don't need any help i'm
self-sufficient god damn it
i didn't i didn't want like the kit just
send me your frozen cheesesteaks from
philly please and i can eat them up like
a boss so wait there's one place that
just does cheese steaks
pats king and steaks in philly we'll
send you
cheese sticks with the whiz and with the
onions what are they frozen
yeah and then you just eat those [ __ ]
up in the oven
man i don't eat that [ __ ] anymore but i
would love to you know what i did get
a vegan version no [ __ ] who does that
but i know jerks
i got bagels i got new york [ __ ]
bagels from where
there's these like five or six different
like new york bagel places where you
gotta heat them up
not even like they just [ __ ] show up
like they're they don't flash freeze
those they don't flash you don't have to
if you put them in a package like you
know
seal them up and today
so yeah the bagels from back east are
better than the bagels from out here
because they got the water
water is different back east than it is
yeah so it makes all the difference
utopia bagels from queens new york big
fat ass bagels huge bagels there's a
bagel joint in red bank new jersey
called bagel station
and the bagels are as big as your
[ __ ] head no lie maybe this big is a
baby's head
[ __ ] huge
but yeah when i first started dating my
wife she lived in red bank and so i take
the train down
and it's like bagel station yeah bagel
station that's three right where the
trains
and cheese yes oh they make the pork
roll egg and cheese too another thing i
can't eat anymore
i have vegan pork roll they i don't know
how they can't
because pork roll doesn't seem like real
meat so no
feels like you could fake it pretty
easily um all right we got
uh did anyone know and say that we
missed a story the only thing that i
kept seeing was
the uh cosmic book news
story which was uh kathleen kennedy's
out and george lucas is returning to
lucasfilm
which cosmic book news looks like comic
book news so people think it's
true um i am sure that
76 year old george lucas is not
returning
to reboot episode seven eight and nine
exactly
so we can i think just put that to rest
the species specious rumor department
yeah but that was it i guess there was
no other big story [ __ ] man i'm gonna be
driving home and remember what it was
and [ __ ]
it's like oh that's right really scott
is making ten commandments no it's gonna
be like oh right i got fired from
masters of the universe
should have said something i have the
exclusive turns out
all right turns out i spoke too much and
revealed too much
um i've you know i can't say anymore
i've seen some more [ __ ] and
yeah god damn it we have a beautiful
show i'm telling you the only
frustrating thing about it is like
having to wait
a year for everyone else to see what i'm
[ __ ] seeing right now
it's [ __ ] magic um all right q a time
folks
normally when we used to do the show
back you know
in olden times in the pre-pre days
when we were onions on our belt as was a
style at the time back when the true
true
existed um we have gotten so desperate
to watch that movie though
that's a [ __ ] pretty good movie you
need three hours and change though i
remember i watched it the first time i
was like oh
oh they're no no no no no i like it oh
it's such a good movie
um all right uh we used to do q and a
with the audience and we give away gifts
[ __ ] we don't we always have tickets to
give out to 40x screenings remember
those
40x screenings where the [ __ ] chair
would practically blow you
old deacon would give us tickets and
whatnot it was such a good time yeah
we'd have like pr
swag that we get sent and we'd just give
it away because it's cluttering up our
house
i've got a giant pile of [ __ ] that i
can't get rid of
because we don't have a crowd to bestow
gifts upon me too poor
[ __ ] brett deacons drowning in 40x
tickets i know
all over the [ __ ] place you can't get
around as well sneakers like [ __ ]
like gambling lifts and he's now like
nine feet tall
because he's got too many tickets he
uses him to fuel his home in the summer
i don't know why he's running a
fireplace but he burns 40x
tickets yells at tickets
it's getting chilly mother what
that's how he lights the stove well he's
got 100 bills just
40 x tickets um that's a long way of
saying like uh boy this used to be so
much better when the people were in the
room but
it's fun to do it with people at home we
can't hear your questions
but they are read to us by the monotone
delivery
of jc riefenberg cameron jc please jc
uh who's our first uh caller all right
uh ryan
ryan marshall had a question well try to
read it like ryan marshall
don't read it like jc create a character
let's imagine who ryan marshall is yeah
real do some [ __ ] research on your
character first
think about the inner life of ryan and
then hit me
let's hear your best i imagine ryan
marshall is a second string
quarterback for uh like police athletic
league team
you're one of them touchy feely
directors it's like you're you're an
animal okay
i'm like the guy that's like just say it
like this all right he's got it right
here's j it's no longer jc we're about
to hear
directly from ryan himself ready for
acting
go jc uh kevin and mark
[ __ ] get back to us that just sounds
like jc there's
no ryan there he didn't even put a voice
on it or nothing he just oh he's kind of
deep
oh hello back up quarterback like he
doesn't have a
nerdy voice that's a character yeah but
that's not right okay well
your ride i'll watch it that's why he's
the backup quarterback yeah
yeah they're like how do you get on the
team all right let's look at that ryan
uh here's ryan marshall yes um hey guys
what is your favorite past comic-con
experience and now say i'm walking here
i'm walking here
nice that's a good question um what was
my best
favorite favorite comic-con experience
tell you my least favorite but i've told
that story many
many times uh let's see
you got one top of your head i'm trying
to think
yeah okay okay uh
this must have been 2015
2016 perhaps no earlier than that like
2013.
i was at the entertainment weekly party
which is the big saturday night ladida i
happen to be working for entertainment
weekly
and that's the only way i got into that
party if you don't do that and if you're
not famous
that is not a party you can just roll up
on um
and i had moderated a panel early in the
day with the women of battlestar
galactica
and at the party i got a little drunk
not like crazy sloppy put me in a car
taking me home drunk but just like
bold i'm starbuck get him in a car
time to go sir you are not starbucks
where's the dagget
yeah and i remember having the most
amazing conversation with mary mcdonald
oh um the president the president my
president
yeah yeah truly um
and she listened to me like a person who
cared about what i was saying
and i remember the very tail end of it i
i told her it's like hey listen i'm
pretty sure it'll be cool with my wife
if you want to come home and live with
us
how'd that go over she said oh you bless
your heart
which is you know go [ __ ] yourself right
but still at least you said live with us
yeah
as opposed to through the drunkenness
been like come home with me
and my wife and [ __ ] with us
and then she's like oh my god this is
this is battlestar galactica all over
again it's like getting attacked by the
cylons all over again
but it was it was it came from this
place of just pure adoration
she's amazing she's amazing she's a
wonderful actress she's a really nice
remember she was stands with a fist yeah
and dances with wolves
totally where she was like i he doesn't
want you to remember she didn't she
hadn't spoken english in so long
that's a good performance man she's
great she's so great she was the first
lady
whitmore in independence day which i
just saw that's right
that's right man what is it better
a better president than a first lady i
would say i think you're right they gave
her more to do
she's one of my favorite moments in that
show where she's like um
you know my father uh my father was a
boxing fan and that means
i love boxing or something like that
very true finish business
is that the episode that's the episode
it's a good episode where they do all
the boxing and [ __ ] they're all beating
the [ __ ] out of each other yeah
because they can't say that they love
each other so they have to punch each
other in the face a lot
until the very end where now i want to
go and watch that episode
yeah um all right so that was my that's
one of my favorite moments not the
favorite but one of my favorite moments
um i've told this before so i'll tell
this and then like throw an addendum
um i don't know what year it was but
stan was still alive and it was within
the last decade me and jason got to
comic-con you pull up into the back
um loading dock area and stuff
and just as we're getting out of our car
getting dropped off
uh stan lee is coming down the ramp to
get into his car and he's like kev
and he always you know [ __ ] was
always so sweet and
wonderful and uh to me when he saw me
and [ __ ] and jason he never remembered
so he's like kev
and kev's little friend and we sat there
chit-chatting and he's like
i said you done for the day he goes yeah
i'm doing something else i said we're
going up to do something right now
he goes okay i'll see you later on and
then he got in the car and took off and
jay was like
man don't you just want to go back in
time and tell young
us that one day we get to comic-con the
first person that greets us
is [ __ ] stan lee and he has a
conversation with us and remembers our
name and i was like well
you remember my name i
i don't know about yours you're my
little friend in point of fact
that was a rather magical moment another
magical moment was
also everything all the good [ __ ]
happens on the loading ducks
which sounds like you know because
that's where i troll for big d
but what and the ymca i used to be a
smoker cigarette smoker
so you would go to loading doc smoke
they don't let you smoke anywhere near
the place
so one time i was down there after they
did the iron man panel
and uh robert downey jr and fabs
and gwen gwyneth paltrow and somebody
else
come off the the elevator like the big
loading dock
roadie version one it might have been
yeah maybe it was terrance howard um but
they come off the elevator
and um i was sitting off to the side
smoking
and favro saw me and i nodded and he
nodded back but he was
holding court with his people they just
come off the stage they just killed and
[ __ ]
and so um robert downey jr
like looked over and saw that
interaction between us and then he looks
at me
and then he smokes right over not smokes
but just
comes right over he goes hey i'm robert
excellent to meet you i've never met you
before and i was like hey man how are
you
like that blew my [ __ ] mind
that [ __ ] he i've been watching that
dude act since i was a kid
you know what i'm saying he was in weird
science for christ's sakes as one of the
[ __ ] i used to watch him on snl long
before you know he became [ __ ]
robert downey jr long before iron man so
that was like [ __ ] i was like
and that was before like the marvel
universe broke [ __ ]
huge man so anyway that was nice and
then the third one i think is like
uh the year they gave me an inkpot award
i really felt like holy [ __ ]
like i'm i'm part of this family i'm a
part of something like you know and i
have been
here for two decades and like that felt
really [ __ ] cool
i love the the comic-con international
folks
um they're they're they're really great
i do love that the inkpot is always a
surprise to the person who gets it
i didn't even know i didn't know it was
historically surprised you got one the
same year i got one the same year but
it's
like it was a spotlight panel i think
that they had on me
which i know plenty of people who have
those panels you know and i don't know
if they're getting pots at the same time
and i'm like all right well [ __ ] it yeah
sure like this is a good year for me
like i think
castle rock was out that year and and i
i was moderating the panel for it
and not a comic book it was like it was
just like a good year it's like oh yeah
totally and then
they gave me a [ __ ] eggplant and i'm
crying like a baby
like just weeping [ __ ] means
something to people like yes we weren't
born
into this [ __ ] like this is [ __ ] we
dreamed about and particularly from the
other side of the goddamn country
to be involved with something like
comic-con to even just [ __ ] go to
comic-con once in your life
and then we started breathing rarefied
air and drinking from [ __ ] rarefied
cups by being able to go
so frequently that it's like ugh gotta
drive down to comic-con
something that like has children we'd be
like [ __ ] kill my parents and yours
to [ __ ] get to comic-con and [ __ ]
so being handed that award was emotional
it's [ __ ]
it's huge man it's like you know it's a
tribe we always wanted to be a part of
and and you know
we we were long a part of it because
that's what's beautiful about that tribe
you just go to it
and you're part of it but then like one
of the elders was like you know here's a
mighty totem that says
you were here you know it's like if you
look at the list of people that won
we're on that [ __ ] list now for time
and memorial we'll be dead
and some kids in the future god willing
to be looking through the list going who
are these people and we'll be told
yeah what's it and then they'll learn
and they go these guys
and like maybe we should create a new
version of inkpot
you know these are quasi futuristic
people
nice um all right that was beautiful
um well done ryan yes
all right so this is alex sands and
alex sands alex sam but why don't we
pretend that alex is a
lady right alex you could go both ways
i mean i mean hopefully alex does go
both ways it'd be so hot on a friday
night but i'm just so interested
intrigued that you're
volunteering to do a woman's voice i
can't do accents so i was like i have my
voice
i have my nerd voice and i could try to
do it later you're like i would try to
do british but i do a better woman
[Laughter]
um all right here we go man we don't
lose our female audience but go ahead
i uh i caught x-men last stand the other
day
wow and it reminded me how underrated
the casting of kelsey grammer was now
some people are like don't do the voice
i'll do the voice
uh what are kevin and mark's most
underrated castings
underrated castings for comic book
movies
uh what was it this person's allocation
grammar as beast
uh kelsey grammer is beast was
underrated was underrated nobody talks
definitely a good call i always i always
liked it but you're right i don't talk
about it much because i don't want to be
shunned in public no i just
it's been a long time since he played
beast but he was good
um underrated casting alan cummings
as uh nightcrawler nightcrawler
look i always loved nightcrawlers a cool
character but that that he was
[ __ ] adorable and sweet and like he's
like the people
they just don't know he made you like
german people again
you know which after world war
ii let's be honest it was a little hard
but [ __ ]
he was so he was like i was in the
munich circus he was so fun and
lovely and nobody talks about it anymore
man they should give him a lot more
roles man
um uh yeah him i'm gonna go with him
what about you
also while he's thinking the guy who
played jensen
in uh iron man oh he's great
it's amazing and that movie is like that
moment in that movie
is fundamentally like the birth of not
the marvel universe because captain
marvel
existed beforehand right but definitely
the birth of iron man
like that suit is just to escape until
like oh i'm gonna choke up talk about
that suit is just to get out of the cave
until jensen's dying and says
don't waste your life and that changes
everything that suit goes from being
a tank to get him out of there to his
salvation
for like almost 10 years oh and that guy
that scene is [ __ ] amazing man
oh i'm getting emotional anyway yeah
back to you
um i feel
awful that i can't remember the
character's name but i remember the
actor who played it
in the in sam raimi's spider-man movies
bill nunn
is playing robbie robbie robbie yes
i wanted to call him ben bradley who is
that guy yeah he was patterned after
but he's robbie reed um he's an amazing
actor and he does so much do the right
thing little
he's radio wrong as many yeah he's radio
rahim himself um
but he does so much with so little in
that movie especially having to share
scenes with jk simmons is
you know just chewing [ __ ] like every
piece of scene through the rafters
he's going um so i love i love him in
that
i i found myself of all of the people in
aquaman
really taken by dolph lundgren as
as mira's dad yeah just because it's
[ __ ] duff lundgren yeah like he
pulled it off too it's like oh that's
what happened to
p-man totally he grew up and went
underwater like if there's gonna be like
one of the kings of atlantis or whatever
he would be one of them
it was good casting for sure um i
wanted them to do a little bit more with
trask in uh
in in x-men whichever one that was yeah
but they
took they brought them back as gimli and
yeah you know an
end game or infinity war yeah as the as
the
giant but yeah it would you know bolivar
trask would have been more
it would have been fun to have more
screen time but that is actually a
pretty good movie that one
of all the x-men movies days of future
past yeah [ __ ] works
it does um i'm trying to think if
there's any others that
[ __ ] show went dead dude it really
did oh my god
it's like the ball back we're dead well
do you have any others
no i i did my list already plus i you
know almost [ __ ] cried
the [ __ ] keeping this [ __ ] together what
more do you want from me uh yeah
beautiful this is two great answers man
you're welcome
out alex alex uh alex
and uh alice and uh
who what would question number three be
this is from michael
and he was curious about what bands and
songs would you assign to other avengers
so iron man is acdc
and uh thor is
led zeppelin the immigrant song what
would you give to the other avengers
hawkeye is billy joel no um
of red let's see black widow is
barracuda
a little bit of heart amendment
amendment amendment amendment amendment
amendment commitment
um who else is there
or there's also the version where black
widow is uh
his meatloafs i won't do that i would do
anything for love but i won't do that
yes a little jim steinman a little
steinman
what do you think that that is in that
song what won't you do
eat ass i would do
anything for love but i won't
eat ass he would never have made it in
in 2019. 2020 he'd be just fine
i don't think anybody's eating ass in
2020 everyone's afraid of the covet
and that's what a colvin hides kids in
the ass
public service announcement from your
good friends and fat man beyond
i mean don't wear a mask just wear a
diaper hammer wear one of them
ass masks because when you fart remember
they [ __ ] told us like two months ago
they're like
you could covert fart and we were like
what the [ __ ]
2020 is taking our farts away
[Laughter]
thankfully they didn't talk about that
no more um all right
all right so black widow you did
barracuda i did won't do that we got a
we got a hulk what do you give hulk oh
[ __ ] part of me wants to do big bottom
crazy train how much eyes are you
wanting
well is ozzie in he's not in yet he's
black sabbath
iron man yeah but iron man is ac dc
they never play iron man no
iron man has played in the credits of
the first iron man but any time tony
stark shows up so it's ac dc
oh right so which seems so weird
so if you've got that's not on the nose
if you've got a
thunder struck
hmm guardians of the galaxy
well they already do it they've got all
the themes
it's a mixtape it's a k-tail classic
um captain america that's an important
one who's captain america what's his
song
bruce springsteen boom well i mean it's
not born in the usa is kind of an anti
yeah propaganda song but still
neil diamond american pie i'm coming to
america
there you go today um
what's that song that they sing it
[ __ ] sweet
character
[Music]
my mind is american pie um yeah don
mclean's got to be the [ __ ] captain
america
oh it's got me more badass than that
what's a [ __ ] america
[ __ ] yeah it's that
it's matt and trey america [ __ ] yeah
what is the hulk's theme song
it can be crazy train but we could
probably do better
i want it to be sad sad rainbow
connection
[Laughter]
someday we'll find it the rainbow
connection
the lovers the dreamers and me
all of us
[Music]
don't now cry a second time i love that
song
oh my god that would totally be his
theme song
um i think that's i think that's the
most fuel we're gonna get out of that
was a good question but i don't think
we're musically ready for
to think about it we gave a good some
good enough answers
based on that we'll give them one more
question all right there are more good
ones in the chat aya the tiger for
captain america
hey man nice shot for hawkeye no hawkeye
would have to be
um
we're done with that question
last question uh if you could bring back
one single season of a show that is
absolutely never coming back
for one new season or a reboot
what show would you want to bring back
i'm gonna i'm i just want to clarify i'm
sticking with the one more season like i
don't want to reboot it if it's a show
that i love i want just one more season
give me one more season original cast
original writers all of it
just give me more of the same uh
[ __ ] i mean sopranos
yeah it's tempting to go like clash just
to see what happens without
tony um
game of thrones just see what happens
after that meeting
yeah bran yeah like hopefully the very
next episode
somebody kills bran and takes over
somebody worthy of leading
yeah but we need the stories no we need
an effective leader who understands
governance yeah we need a warrior
i'm sorry i don't know what you are
anymore
um i i would like more parks and
recreation
i would take another season of that no
uh i take another season of battle star
until a couple years ago i would have
said oh i would take another season of
roseanne
things change yeah on a dime they turn
another battle star that ended though
what would they do for another season
it'd be like they got to earth
that's all i ever wanted welcome to
earth yeah they meet [ __ ] will smith
boom that's what happens at the end of
that next season we probably talked
about it here but i've been talking
about i think we did
but just since we're talking about
remember
online a couple weeks ago they talked
about the i've read something online a
factoid where the
the simpsons creators writers people
that run the show
al jean mike rice have had a break the
glass plan
in place for years on
what the last episode would be in case
you know fox or disney whoever was like
okay
you're finally done and it is [ __ ]
brilliant
do we know what it is yes do you want to
know it
yeah the spoilers in case you never
wanted to know
[ __ ] tune out this is what i read
this is what they said
okay shoot if the word came down we're
like you're done
they've got the script already written
it's in a drawer
they just pull it out it goes in to get
[ __ ] animated and [ __ ]
this episode takes place
on a day and then ends
at night time and the nighttime
ending of the very last episode of the
simpsons
is the simpsons getting ready to go to
the christmas pageant
in the very first episode of the
simpsons the simpsons christmas special
wow so it becomes one gigantic [ __ ]
loop
how awesome is that that's [ __ ] that
means when you get to the end
it doesn't ever [ __ ] end mark the
simpsons just happens
over and over again that's my idea of
heaven
if that is heaven i'll [ __ ] happily
die um
i would then like every show to do that
everybody should [ __ ]
really tag up with the start man so you
just like and we're off
that's brilliant um that is brilliant
what a way to go out on
totally cool piece of trivia like that
which i
read online and i hope the [ __ ] is true
and you know what it's 20 20.
i'm gonna choose to believe that it's
true cause i need some [ __ ] to cling to
man
i would like i'd also like one more
season of the nick did you ever watch
the nick
i did not you should watch the nick you
would you'd dig it though i would dig it
yeah you dig it the most it's a
soderberg joint right it's yeah
soderbergh directed every episode
what yeah all bonds he's got five owen
clive owen um andre holland who's
amazing
um but yeah it's all set at a turn of
the century 1900's
um hospital in new york the
knickerbocker and it
it manages to do the thing that that
great fiction can do which is find it
find a way to be contemporary even if
you're period so even though it's
literally 1900 in new york it's about
gender it's about class
it's about race it's about ethnicity
it's about science it's about
you know cutting edge it's about pain
and drug use and all of these things
and it's gorgeous and it's so well acted
and there's there's one episode i want
to say it's the penultimate episode of
the first season
where there's a riot there's a race riot
in this hospital because andre holland
plays a black doctor
and in 1900 there was not a ton of black
doctors let alone black surgeons
and there's a there's a race riot it's
the most harrowing riot
i've ever seen on film and it's more
harrowing than the one in uh
the tulsa massacre that's not a riot as
much as
that's yeah an attack an attack um and
but this is more personal
like it's the the perspective of that
scene
is so intimate and so and so close
to the characters involved it's just
it's it's phenomenal
you sold the ticket i'm gonna go watch
that [ __ ] um but yeah one more
season of that i would i would love
good question yeah man that's the one to
go out on [ __ ] yeah you remind me
sing-songy questions and [ __ ]
um did you have a good time listen to
two guys talk about
same [ __ ] you could have talked about
with your friends we have as much
insight into it
as you do we're so glad you chose to
spend you could have gotten your own
news
could do it but why bother why search
let's do that for you why google when
you've got bernard instead
why google when you can mark um it is
ask
jeeves yes our modern day ass chiefs
um it is uh like all good things uh time
to end this [ __ ] man
uh we thank jc for letting us mount
this show if you will um at the scum and
villainy cantina
holding the crowds at bay as soon as the
show's done
100 people pile into this bar remember
those days
just sniffing covet farts oh man i can't
wait
um don't forget it's comic-con weekend
so you can watch comic-con events
all weekend long online don't forget
if you're anywhere in these united
states go to moviespopup.com
right now order yourself a movie's meal
kit man you won't be sorry
um i'm about to turn 50. i know
very very soon what is the date today
the 24th yeah it's the 24th
so a week we'll do one more show of me
at 49 and then
i will be 50. speaking of 49 uh speaking
of one more show
rather um the show that we're doing this
week
is not on friday it will be on thursday
we'll do it next thursday is that
correct
next thursday fat man beyond next friday
scum and villainy will be live all day
it's harry potter's 40th birthday
on friday what do you mean 40th so if
harry potter
was a real person was a real person and
he was age
10 or whatever when the first book came
out he'd be middle-aged he'd be turning
40 on friday so we're gonna do an
all-day birth live stream birthday party
with candy
members younger kiss and then bring his
age back down
if i'm him i'm never not 25.
is he wait how did how did we get to 40
because he was born
40 years ago so the books aren't 40 the
character the character
when the books came out in like 94
harry potter was 10 and it's been 30
years or that that math isn't correct
but
okay harry potter is my age so i'm
turning 40 at the end of this year
it all comes back to jc he really does
he's like harry potter's just like me i
live under the stairs and i'm persecuted
as well
jesus christ rifenbach and one day
jesus christ it's all about him
jc rife um there it is folks [ __ ] we've
had a good time man
we have comic-con at home enjoy it this
weekend
we'll see you on thursday uh in the
meantime anything else any other
housekeeping man i got nothing
there it is sometimes that's it that's
all the news we feel like we're
forgetting a big story though
really right and then like we'll go home
and we're like oh that's right
yeah it was like [ __ ] baby yoda's
name
is
baby got his own show the [ __ ] uh
thanks for hanging out with us folks
thanks for listening to us
chit chat about the things that matter
to us there is no show without the guy
standing over there give it up
for mr mark bernardin ladies and
gentlemen oh thank you sir
it is good to spend a
diminished comic-con with you yes
in a perfect world we'd be in front of
people at the american comedy club
yes 200 screaming people happy to be
there and then we'd vanish into the
night of the gaslamp district
like heroes but now instead we will put
on masks
hustle through the poop ridden back
alley
quickly get into our cars and try to
race the virus back to our house so we
can get in the door before it gets in
the door
such a different outdoor we're living in
the back door we're living because as we
know
butt covert as we said we're living in
[ __ ] omega man
we really are we are charlton heston and
what was the other version
i am legend yeah oh my god mary tyler
moore or mega man i should make it and
even i am legends not a current
reference no that's 20 years old we are
living in i am legend right now
yeah i mean there's less things going to
like howl and kill you
but wow you haven't walked around
downtown los angeles my friend
that's that's true a lot of
yuppies
that's still a thing they came back from
the 80s and uh omega man are going to
come in and howl at you from the side of
the street
um there's a version of omega man where
all the zombies are really just yuppies
i mean i think that's everywhere the
remake in the 80s uh there it is folks
thank you
for hanging out with us man for fat man
beyond i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
tune in on thursday same fat time same
fat channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
for the good of all cree